SONIA SHAH: Hello.
Thank you guys for coming.
I'm Sonia Shah.
I'm a science journalist.
I've spent the last six
years looking at pandemics.
And when I first started
writing this book-- this
is my fourth book-- when I first
started writing it in 2010,
I certainly didn't
think we'd actually
be living through a pandemic
of a brand-new pathogen right
when it came out.
But of course here we
are, with the Zika virus
washing over the Americas.
And it's a really
good example of what's
been going on globally,
and why I decided
to write this book in the first
place, which is that we've had,
over the past 50 years, over
300 infectious pathogens that
have either newly
emerged or reemerged
into new places where they
never have been seen before.
So Zika's really
just the latest one.
We've had Ebola in
West Africa, where
it hadn't been seen before,
novel kinds of avian
influenzas that infect
birds and also some of them
infect humans, new
kinds of coronaviruses
that cause diseases like SARS,
a new one that's coming out
of the Middle East called
Middle East Respiratory
Syndrome, new kinds of
tick-borne illnesses,
mosquito-borne viruses
from dengue to chikungunya
to West Nile virus.
So the sense that
a pandemic, that
is, an outbreak of disease that
starts in one part of the world
and then spreads like a wave
across global populations,
is definitely growing.
And that's not just the
opinion of the worried well,
as they call us,
but also experts.
This is a survey that was done
in 2006 of emerging disease
experts.
And the majority said
that a pandemic that
would sicken a billion
people, kill 165 million,
and cost the global
economy $3 trillion
would occur sometime in
the next two generations.
So the big question
is, of course,
which pathogen is going to cause
this death and destruction?
And we have a lot of
potential candidates.
150,000 species of bacteria,
nearly a million viruses that
can infect mammals-- so
picking out which one of these
will cause the next
pandemic may not be so easy.
But while we can't
know which one,
we can potentially
know how it happens.
Because historically,
only a very few microbes
have been able to
cause pandemics.
We've had Yersinia pestis, which
caused the Plague, influenza,
which causes influenza
pandemics, Variola which causes
smallpox, HIV, which causes
the ongoing HIV pandemic,
and then the fifth
one is cholera.
This is the one that
interests me the most,
in part because
it's very deadly.
Cholera kills about half
of the people who get it,
if they're not rapidly treated.
But also because cholera is
one of the most successful
of our pandemic-causing
pathogens.
It hasn't caused just
one or two pandemics.
It's actually caused
seven pandemics.
And the latest one is going on
right now just a few 100 miles
off the coast of
Florida in Haiti.
So we think of cholera today
as a poor person's disease.
And that is basically true now.
But it wasn't true when cholera
was a brand-new disease.
When cholera first emerged
in the 19th century,
it hit some of the most advanced
cities of the time-- cities
like New York, which was
plagued by repeated epidemics
of cholera in the 1800s.
And not just New York
City-- London, Paris,
New Orleans-- all these places
were plagued by this scourge.
And thousands of people died.
But it wasn't just deadly.
These epidemics are very
disruptive, as well.
And this is sort of a hallmark
of new pathogens, which
is when they
emerge, people don't
know why they suddenly arrived.
They don't know how
they're transmitted, how
they're spread between people.
And they often start
to blame each other.
So in the 1830s, the cholera
was blamed on the Irish.
In the 1840s, it
was the Muslims.
By the 1890s, it was
the Eastern Europeans
who were getting
blamed for the cholera.
And this wasn't just
social exclusion.
This was actually violent--
violent assaults as well.
This picture is
of smashed skulls
that were scarred
by bullets that
were found in a mass grave.
It was excavated outside
of Philadelphia in 2009.
And what had happened
there is, in 1832,
a bunch of Irish
immigrants were working
on a stretch of railway track.
And there had been
a cholera outbreak.
And the local community
quarantined the valley
that the Irish workers
are staying in.
But then they also secretly came
back and massacred all of them,
and buried them in this mass
grave, which we just recently
found.
But it wasn't just
marginalized groups
that were attacked during
these outbreaks of disease.
It was also healthcare workers.
So doctors were routinely
stoned in the streets
during cholera outbreaks.
Quarantine hospitals
were surrounded by mobs.
A lot of them were burnt down.
So the question I
wanted to ask is,
how does a microbe cause all
of this death and destruction?
When you think about
a microbe, it's
this little, tiny,
microscopic thing
with no independent
locomotion at all.
And yet it can cause
all of this devastation,
and impact human history
in such a profound way.
And so what I wanted to look at
is, what are the drivers that
turn a microbe into a pandemic?
Cholera started in
the environment,
which is where a
lot of new microbes
are coming out of today.
It comes out of a place
called the Sundarbans.
This is pictured here.
It's where the major
rivers of South Asia
drain into the Bay of Bengal.
And the water here is
half salty, half fresh.
It's quite warm.
It's quite alkaline.
And the bacteria that
causes cholera actually
lives naturally in
this environment,
and in similar environments
around the world.
It lives in conjunction
with zooplankton.
And it actually is a peaceful
and useful inhabitant
in that environment.
It helps recycle nutrients.
And for a long
time, people didn't
live in places like the
superabundance of course
it's covered in mangrove
swamps the crocodiles there's
tigers there's cyclones.
It's flooded by the
tides twice a day.
That all changed, of
course, when the British Raj
decided to colonize
the Sundarbans
and turn it into rice farms.
And this happened over the
course of the 19th century.
Over 90% of the Sundarbans
was settled by people.
So quite suddenly, humans
had invaded the habitat
of the cholera bacteria.
And this allowed the bacteria
to spill over into our bodies.
And inside the human
body, the cholera bacteria
performs a very
different function
than it does in its
natural environment.
So if you ingest a little
bit of cholera bacteria,
the bacteria will line
the interior of your gut.
And it actually reverses
the normal functioning
of that organ, so that instead
of nourishing the tissues
in the body with fluids, the
cholera-infected gut actually
extracts fluids out of
the body and expels them
in a massive torrent of
watery diarrhea and vomiting.
In fact, a person
infected with cholera
can lose 15 liters
of fluid a day.
And that's what kills
you from cholera.
You basically just
dehydrate to death.
You desiccate.
It can happen in
a matter of hours.
So the first pandemic of
cholera began in the Sundarbans
in 1817.
It started traveling
up into Russia, out
into this newly industrializing
cities of the Old World.
But of course, to
cause a pandemic,
it has spread across
to global populations.
It would have to
cross the Atlantic.
And all of this is happening
right at the transition
from sail to steam.
So instead of taking eight
weeks to cross the Atlantic,
over the course of the
early 1800s, suddenly
it was taking more
like one week.
And once we started
building steamships,
we could go not just down our
rivers but up them as well.
And then we used steam
engines to build canals,
like the Erie Canal
which opened in 1825.
And that connected all
these waterways together.
So we had this nice
network of waterways.
It's like a highway system.
And it was perfect for cholera
to come over from London
to Paris, over the
Atlantic into Canada,
and thence filter throughout
the interior of North America.
And of course, at this time we
were urbanizing really rapidly.
This was a new form
of living in cities.
People are rushing
out of the farms
into the cities for
new factory jobs.
Places like New York City were
becoming incredibly crowded.
Of course, there were no
subway hookups and highways
to let people sprawl
outside of the city center.
So everyone had
to live near work
or the possibility of work.
In the most crowded
parts of New York City,
there was about 77,000
people per square kilometer.
So that's six times more
crowded than modern-day Tokyo.
It's also 1,000
times more crowded
than anyone had ever lived
before-- brand-new way
of living.
So suddenly, people are
really close together,
breathing each other.
They're touching
each other more.
And they also created
a huge sanitary crisis.
So when people moved from
the farms to the cities,
they didn't come up with a new
way of managing human waste.
They basically just used that
old system in the new place.
And the old system was simply
to use outhouses and privies
and cesspools, and let the
human waste just kind of sink
into the ground and decompose.
So that works OK in places where
there is not a lot of crowding,
and there's enough
room for, and space
for, this stuff to decompose.
But that's not what
happened in New York
City and similar
industrialized cities.
Across New York, there's
about 1/12 of the city
was covered with cesspools,
privies, and outhouses.
There was no such sewer system
to carry this stuff away
and to treat it.
There weren't even
any rules, actually,
that you had to empty out
your outhouses or cesspools.
So all of this
material was allowed
to simply sink into the ground,
spill over into the streets,
spill over into people's
wells, and then down
into the groundwater.
The typical 19th
century New Yorker
was ingesting
about two teaspoons
of fecal matter every day.
So you can imagine when cholera
came into a city like that,
it just exploded.
And this happened
time and time again.
Now, there were things that they
could have done even back then.
But there were
political problems, too.
So the public health
infrastructure
had just started out.
And meanwhile, this was the
era of the robber barons.
Private interests had
become incredibly powerful.
And when they objected to
certain public health measures,
they were not inactive.
For example, in 1832,
the Governor of New York
actually sent a doctor up to
upstate New York and Canada
to see what was happening--
to do surveillance,
see if cholera is going to
threaten the City of New York.
And this is the data that
that doctor collected
in 1832, which we've mapped.
It shows a pretty clear picture.
Cholera is coming
down the Hudson River.
It's coming down the Erie Canal.
And it's heading straight
for New York City.
So the obvious
thing, then, would
have been to enact a
quarantine on the waterways.
But they didn't, because
private interests
decided that that would be
far too disruptive to trade.
And so cholera was allowed
to come down these waterways
again and again.
In fact, there
were companies that
were making money selling
cholera-contaminated water
to the people of New York.
The epicenter of a lot of the
cholera epidemics happened
in a slum called Five Points,
which is pictured here.
If you've ever seen the movie
"Gangs of New York," the Martin
Scorsese movie, that's
actually about Five Points.
So this was the epicenter of a
lot of the cholera epidemics.
And this slum, unlike
the rest of Manhattan,
which is built on
bedrock, this slum
was actually built on
what was once a pond.
It was the only source of
fresh water in Manhattan.
That pond had been
filled up with garbage.
And then the slum had
been built on top of it.
So the ground underneath
the slum was very unstable.
It was low lying.
And of course, the
groundwater underneath it
was very easily
contaminated with all
of the outhouses and privies
of the slum on top of it.
But the company that the
State of New York chartered
to deliver drinking water
to the people of New York,
rather than tap upstream sources
of water-- which they knew
would be fresher and which
would taste better-- they
decided to save money,
kind of like what
happened in Flint, Michigan.
They sank their well right
in the middle of that slum.
And they delivered
that water to one-third
of the people of New York.
And this happened repeatedly
throughout the 1800s.
And the reason they did that--
actually, the person who
was behind all of these
machinations that allowed this
to happen was the notorious
Aaron Burr, who we all
love to hate now-- the bad
boy of the American founding.
And the reason he did
that is because he wanted
to start a bank-- the Bank
of the Manhattan Company,
of course, which ended up
being incredibly powerful.
Do any of you guys know
what the bank of the company
is called today?
It's JP Morgan Chase-- the
biggest bank in the country.
So it wasn't just political
defenses that failed.
It was also medical
Doctors simply applied their
thinking on old diseases
to the new disease.
So the old way of
thinking about diseases
was that they were caused
by what were called miasmas.
These were basically
stinky airs that
rise up from decomposing
organic material.
And the idea is
that these stinky
airs-- if you inhale
them, you get sick.
I mean, this is based on a
2000-year-old Hippocratic
theory.
And it made a certain
amount of sense
for old diseases like,
say, malaria, which
isn't carried by stinky air.
But certainly the mosquitoes
that carry malaria
would be more likely to
exist in the sulfurous airs
around swamps and
things like that.
But when applied to a
new disease like cholera,
miasmatism could make
the disease much worse.
So for example, in
the city of London,
over the course of
the 1700s and 1800s,
people had started
installing water closets,
or what we know
as flush toilets.
And they thought this would
be really healthy for them,
because it would get rid of all
the bad smells of human waste.
You rid the stuff, read
the smell out of your home,
out of your street, and
just flush it all away.
But the thing is, they didn't
care about the contents
of the flushed toilets.
All they cared
about was the smell.
So they didn't mind
that the contents of all
of these flush toilets
was dumped directly
into the River Thames, which
was their drinking water.
And in fact, after
every cholera outbreak
the people of London
installed more flush
toilets to dump more
of their human waste
into the drinking
water, rather than less.
So the other question
I wanted to ask
is, could this happen again?
And I went around to
places where new pathogens
are emerging today to try to
see how the story of cholera
could shed light on
what might happen
with these other new pathogens.
And what I found is,
those same drivers
that brought cholera into
human populations in the 1900s
are being recreated today,
but on a global scale.
So we're invading wild habitat
on a scale never seen before.
And that's because our
populations are growing,
and also, our industrial
developments are growing.
And what this means is that
we're disrupting and invading
a lot of wildlife habitat.
And as we do that, humans come
into novel, intimate contact
with different wild
animals, wild species.
And that allows the microbes
that live in their bodies
to spill over into our bodies.
And a great example
of that is Ebola.
So this whole swath of
the continent of Africa
has been deforested
pretty steadily,
not just because of urbanization
and farms growing, and mines,
and things like that, but also
because of political violence.
Those three countries
on the westernmost side
of Africa-- Sierra Leone,
Guinea, and Liberia--
where those three
countries meet was once
one of the most biodiverse
forests in the world.
But over the course
of the 1990s,
there was an incredibly
complex political conflict--
very bloody, went on for years.
And one result of that
was 600,000 refugees
fled into that forest
to escape the fighting.
And what happened to that
forest is visible from space.
The inset in this picture
shows where that forest is--
those three countries meet.
And the inset is from 1970.
It shows almost all green.
The bigger picture is from 1999.
And that's a satellite
picture-- the same one.
And it shows that area where
those three countries meet.
It's mostly all brown,
because only 15%
of that original
forest remained.
And what we now know
is that whole area
that's been deforested
overlaps pretty well
with the habitat of fruit bats.
And fruit bats, as we now know,
is a reservoir of Ebola virus.
And as people come into
novel, intimate contact
with fruit bats, the viruses
and microbes that live in bats
spill over into our bodies.
And that's exactly what
happened in December 2013,
when a two-year-old child who
lived near that deforested area
where those three
countries meet-- we
know he was playing near a tree
where bats were known to roost.
And so maybe he touched some
bat saliva or some bat excreta.
However it happened, the
Ebola virus from the bat
got into this boy's body.
And he got sick.
And before he died, he
infected his family members.
And they infected their
healthcare workers.
And they infected
their family members,
until we had the biggest
outbreak of Ebola
in history-- bigger than all
previous outbreaks of Ebola
combined.
Over 11,000 people died.
But this isn't just
happening in far-off places.
This is happening right here
in the United States, too.
West Nile virus, for
example-- West Nile virus
is a virus of migratory birds.
They come from Africa.
They fly over here by
the millions every year,
because-- especially in
places like New York--
it's on a flyaway.
So they land here a lot.
But we didn't have West
Nile virus in people
until 1999, because we
had a very diverse bird
flock around us.
We had birds like
woodpeckers, and rails,
and other bird species.
And those birds actually
repel the virus.
So as long as you have a
lot of diverse bird species
around, including
woodpeckers and rails,
you don't have that
much West Nile virus
around in your
domestic bird flocks.
And you're not so likely to
get West Nile virus in humans.
But what happened over
the past 25 years is,
we've lost a lot of
that biodiversity.
So right now, actually
in last 25 years,
American Robin populations
have doubled as the woodpeckers
and rails have vanished.
So of course,
robins and crows can
live in any kind of
broken environment.
But woodpeckers and rails can't.
And it turns out that,
unlike woodpeckers and rails,
robins and crows are excellent
amplifiers of West Nile virus.
So the fewer woodpeckers
and rails you have around,
and the more robins and
crows you have around,
the more West Nile
virus you have around.
And the more likely it
is that a mosquito will
bite an infected bird
and then bite a human,
and trigger an epidemic.
And that's exactly
what happened in 1999,
with the first outbreak of West
Nile virus in New York City.
And since then, the
virus has steadily
spread across the nation.
This map is all
the counties where
West Nile virus-infected
birds have been found.
Similarly, in the Northeastern
forest, when it was intact
we had a diversity
of woodland species.
We had chipmunks.
We had opossum.
We had deer and mice.
And these animals helped
control tick populations.
The typical opossum actually
destroys 6,000 ticks a week
through grooming.
But what we've done
is we've broken
this forest up into a
little patchwork quilt
as we've expanded our suburbs
into the Northeastern forests.
And opossums and
chipmunks-- they
don't survive well in
that broken environment.
But what do have a lot
of is deer and mice.
While the typical possum will
destroy 6,000 ticks a week,
the typical mouse destroys
about 50 ticks a week.
So the fewer opossums you have
around and the more mice you
have around, the more ticks you
have around and the more likely
it is that an outbreak
of tick-borne disease
will happen in humans.
And that's exactly what
happened in the late 1970s
in Connecticut with the first
outbreak of Lyme disease.
And that has steadily
crossed the country, as well.
We have about 300,000 Americans
diagnosed with Lyme disease
every year.
So we're driving pathogens
into human populations
in all these different ways.
But then we're
also offering them
these fantastic amplification
opportunities, just
like those slums in New York
City in the 19th century.
So that process of urbanization
that started back then
is really reaching its peak now.
By 2030, the majority
of the human species
will live in cities.
And they're not
going to be cities
like New York and Seattle.
They're going to be cities more
like Monrovia and Freetown--
lots of ad hoc development,
not a lot of infrastructure,
and a lot of slums.
About two billion
people are expected
to be living in slums by 2030.
And there are pathogens
that are already exploiting
this-- new pathogens.
Ebola is one example.
We've had Ebola outbreaks
since the 1970s.
But they've always been
really relatively small
and contained,
because they never
infected any place that had more
than a few 100,000 inhabitants.
Within a few weeks of
emerging in Guinea in 2013,
Ebola had reached
three capital cities
with a combined population
of nearly three million.
And this is one
important reason why it
was such a huge conflagration.
Similarly, Zika virus is
exploiting urbanization, too.
We've had Zika at
least since the 1940s.
But it was carried
by a forest mosquito
in the equatorial forests
of Africa and Asia.
And that forest mosquito didn't
really bite people that much.
It lived in the forest.
It mostly bit animals.
Today, Zika is being
carried by a mosquito called
Aedes aegypti.
This is a mosquito
that has dramatically
expanded its range
as we have urbanized,
especially in the tropics.
It can breed in a drop
of water in a bottle cap.
It loves all of
our plastic garbage
that we leave lying around.
And on top of that,
it only bites humans.
So it's one important reason
why Zika is now exploding so
dramatically in the Americas.
But we're not just
offering crowds of people
to our pathogens to amplify.
We're also offering
them crowds of animals.
We have more animals
under domestication
today than in the last
10,000 years of domestication
up until 1960
combined-- huge number
of animals as our
demand for meat goes up
and the demand for protein.
And a lot of these
animals are being
kept in the animal equivalent of
a slum, which are these factory
farms, where there's a million
or more individuals crammed
really closely together.
And this offers pathogens
other opportunities to amplify.
One example is avian influenza.
So avian influenza normally
lives in wild waterfowl,
like ducks and goose and stuff.
And it doesn't really
make them sick.
But when those viruses
drop into a factory
farm full of
captive chickens, it
starts to replicate really
wildly, and mutate, and evolve,
and become more virulent.
And this has happened
again and again
with increasing frequency
as factory farming has
spread in Asia, where we have
most of our wild waterfowl.
And some of these
mutated viruses
can actually infect
humans as well.
And this is, of course,
creating a new sanitary crisis.
We have about 2.6 billion people
around the world today who have
no access to modern sanitation.
So they're living in
19th century standards
already, to this day.
But on top of that, we also have
seven billion tons of animal
excreta to manage every year.
And this is far more than our
croplands can possibly absorb,
which is how we used
to manage animal waste.
So what farmers are doing
is collecting all this stuff
in giant manure lagoons, which
is what these pits are called.
They're basically
just untreated,
unlined cesspools
of animal waste.
And so when it rains,
or if there's storms,
all of this material gets
out into the environment.
And this is one reason why
we have an increasing problem
with virulent forms of E. coli.
You probably heard of
killer hamburger virus.
These are caused by viruses like
shiga toxin-producing E. coli.
And this microbe
normally lives in cattle.
About half of all American
cattle on feedlots
is infected with shiga
toxin-producing E. coli.
It doesn't really
make them sick.
But because cattle manure
so often contaminates
our food and water, we
have about 7,000 Americans
getting sick with shiga
toxin-producing E.
coli every year.
And then of course,
we're carrying this stuff
around in the most
efficient method possible,
which is our flight network.
We don't just have a few
airports in capital cities,
but thousands of airports,
even in small towns,
and hundreds of thousands
of connections between them.
So when a pathogen emerges
in one part of the world,
it can very rapidly spread
through the rest of the globe,
as this simulation
of a flu pandemic
shows on this geographic map.
And in fact, you can predict
where an epidemic will strike
next, simply by
measuring the number
of direct flights between
infected and uninfected cities.
So this is the same flu pandemic
on a map of cities as connected
by direct flights.
And when you run that
simulation, on a map like this,
it's just a perfect
series of waves.
So we're driving these
pathogens into our populations.
But of course, we have a lot of
defenses-- and better defenses
now than we did in
the 19th century.
And yet we still have
similar challenges.
Of the 100 biggest
economies in the world
today, only 49 are governments.
51 are corporations.
And so when our public health
strategies come into conflict
with private interests, we're
not able to implement them.
And a good example of that is
antibiotic-resistant bacteria.
We've known since the 1980s
that if you use antibiotics
in a way that's not
medically necessary,
you will trigger the evolution
of antibiotic-resistant
bacteria.
But today, all of that
blue part of that pie chart
is commercial use
of antibiotics.
That's 80% of the
antibiotics that
are consumed in the
United States are
used for commercial reasons.
That is, farmers give them in
low doses to their livestock
to help fatten them
for market so they can
bring them to market faster.
So it's really
just a tiny sliver
of our antibiotic consumption
that is medically necessary.
And yet attempts to control
this have failed again and again
since the 1970s.
We've just barely started
making kind of baby steps
towards reining
in this practice.
And we have 23,000
people dying of
antibiotic-resistant bacteria
every year as a result.
Now, our medicine
is far superior
than it was in the 19th
century, of course.
We can very rapidly come up with
cures and drugs and vaccines
for new pathogens.
But I would argue there
is still a mismatch.
So a lot of these pathogens
are coming out of wildlife
or coming out of animals.
They're coming through
human populations,
being driven by social
and political factors.
So you would think, then,
that the best way to contain
these threats is through
a multidisciplinary kind
of collaborative process.
You get the wildlife biologist.
You get the ecologist,
get the epidemiologist,
you get the doctors.
You get the social scientists
and the anthropologists
and the political scientists,
and you approach it that way.
But that's not what we do.
So we think of
contagious disease
as solely a biomedical problem.
And one example of what
happens is dengue in Florida,
and how that was managed.
Dengue virus is
carried by mosquitoes.
It first emerged in
Florida in 2009--
hadn't been seen
there in 70 years.
And we immediately attacked
it as a biomedical problem.
We mobilized our resources
to target the mosquito,
target the virus with killing
chemicals-- sort of attacked
this invasion of
mosquitoes and virus.
In fact, though,
Florida has been
surrounded by places where
there's dengue for a long time.
The mosquitoes that carry dengue
have been present in Florida
for a long time.
So there wasn't actually
any invasion to repel.
What had happened is in 2008,
we had the foreclosure crisis.
And it hit Florida
particularly hard.
And since it's
Florida, when there's
a lot of abandoned
homes around, there's
also a lot of empty
swimming pools.
And when the rains came, all of
these abandoned swimming pools
started to fill up
with standing water.
And they became giant
mosquito hatcheries.
And a year later, we had
this unprecedented outbreak
of dengue in Florida.
Now, would have addressing
the housing crisis
have helped prevent
or even contain
the dengue outbreak in Florida?
I don't know, because
nobody tried that.
What I do know is arguably,
the biomedical response
has failed, in the sense that
we keep attacking dengue,
but now it's considered
endemic in Florida.
Dengue's considered
a permanent part
of the landscape
of Florida today.
So what can we do about it?
This is not a crystal
ball, of course.
This is not Nostradamus.
This is not what's
definitely going to happen.
This is what's going to
happen if we don't change.
And there's a lot
of things I think
we can do to mitigate
the risk of pandemics.
This is a typical
epidemic curve.
It shows cases over time
that occur in a completely
susceptible population.
So the pathogen starts
to cause some sickness,
and then it starts to
grow exponentially.
It reaches a peak when
the majority of people
have either been sick and
have died, or have been sick
and recovered.
And then the epidemic
will start to collapse.
So our present system of
surveillance for new diseases--
the best we can do
at the moment is
start to attack these
things right about there,
where that arrow is.
So exponential growth
of untreatable disease
has already begun.
And so to contain
it at that point,
you need almost perfect control.
You need to stamp out
every single case,
because you already
have exponential growth.
But what if you push that
back just a little bit?
And that is now possible.
We don't know
which pathogens are
going to cause
the next pandemic,
but since we do know how,
we can predict where.
And this map is a map
of disease hotspots.
It's places where there is a
lot of invasion of wildlife
habitat, a lot of
intensification of agriculture,
of livestock agriculture,
a lot of slums,
a lot of flight connections, or
some combination of all of that
together.
And these are places
where scientists
believe new pathogens are
most likely to emerge.
So we can do, in these
places, active surveillance,
so that going out
into the environment,
looking out wildlife, looking
at people on the front lines who
are dealing with
wildlife, and trying
to track how microbes
might be changing,
and stamp them out before
they start to spread.
And there's an ad hoc group
of academic groups, NGOs,
some government actors
who are actually doing
this kind of work right now.
Of course, all of us need to
become responsible citizens,
too, in this new
age of pandemics.
And that's doing
some obvious things,
like washing hands, and staying
away from antibiotics, avoiding
factory meats, and all that.
But we also need to just be
informed that each pathogen is
different.
Because I think the big
missing piece in the whole way
we approach pandemics
is public engagement.
We really leave this all up
to the biomedical experts.
Instead, we all need to
be engaged in the rising
risks of the way we live today.
And ultimately, I think what
the history of pandemics
has taught me is that all
these things are connected.
Human health is connected to
the health of our societies,
the health of our animals,
the health of our wildlife,
the health of our ecosystems.
These are all connected.
So we need to kind
of re-imagine the way
we think of ourselves
in this microbial world
that we all live in.
And ultimately, I think it is
possible to prevent pandemics
altogether, by just changing
the conditions that give rise
to them.
We could do things like
restore wild habitat
so that microbes that live
in animals stay in animals
and don't spill over
into human bodies.
We can do things like protect
the health of the most
vulnerable among
us-- the people who
are living without
sanitation, the people who
are living in slums, the animals
who are living in their factory
farm slums.
Because their health is now
very obviously connected
to the rest of us, too.
And I'm happy to take questions.
Thank you so much for listening.
[APPLAUSE]
Anyone?
I stunned them all into silence.
Well, great.
Oh, here we go.
AUDIENCE: I guess
I'll ask a question.
I really loved the talk.
And I loved the way you
were able to connect
so many disparate
modes of our lives,
and to be able to see it all
together in this public health
way.
A question I have
is that, so you're
talking about these pandemics,
that one of the older pandemics
that you just mentioned
earlier, which
is the bubonic
plague-- so there,
they did not have a lot of the
post-Industrial Revolution,
interconnected world kind
of aspects we have now.
Obviously, they also
didn't have germ theory
and modern medicine.
But what was it
that caught there?
How did that become as
big a pandemic as the ones
that we have now, post
steamship and airplane and all
these other things.
SONIA SHAH: I haven't studied
the history of plague,
so I'm not sure exactly
what the main factors were.
But certainly one big
difference is those pandemics
were so much slower.
And I think what's
so disruptive today
is the speed with which
these things can pass.
Because when we have
new diseases that
come into a population
slowly, we can build immunity.
We can adapt to it.
And in fact, sometimes they
become even more entrenched.
And so I'm wondering
if with plague,
since those pandemics were so
very slow, that the drivers
would be quite different.
And the way we would have
adapted to living with plague
would have been quite different.
I mean, cholera came
through incredibly fast.
Because there'd be one
ship that would arrive,
and this bacteria would
get into the water system.
And bang, everyone would be
getting sick all at once.
And that's something very unique
about these highly virulent
pathogens that can
spread so rapidly.
So plague is quite
different in that sense.
AUDIENCE: So 19th century New
York, there's a lot of poverty.
I look around now, and I see a
lot of plump, healthy people.
I wonder if we have examples
of pandemics exploding
in plump, healthy populations?
SONIA SHAH: Sure, HIV.
AUDIENCE: Good one.
SONIA SHAH: There you go.
Yeah, absolutely.
But you're right.
So our immune status and
our nutritional status
play a big role in
how sick we get.
And we saw this with Ebola,
for example, where it really
seemed that people who had
a different immune status,
and were maybe more
nutritionally sound or intact
were surviving it better.
So you're right.
So that's going to
protect us to some degree.
But of course,
pathogens are very wily.
A pathogen is a microbe that
just fills the new niche
that we provide to it.
So we provide lots
of healthy bodies
that are easy to get
from one to the other,
it'll take advantage
of that, too.
And HIV is just one example.
AUDIENCE: First, I want to say
thanks for coming and giving
this talk.
I got in a little
late, so I don't know
if you already touched on this.
But I heard you mention Zika
briefly during your talk.
So I was just
wondering, do you feel
like was the Olympics--
do you think that could
be a big factor in its spread?
Or in the big picture, it
doesn't really matter much?
SONIA SHAH: So Zika
virus is carried
by Aedes aegypti mosquitoes.
In August, it'll be winter
in the southern hemisphere.
So this mosquito is very
sensitive to climatic factors.
It needs at least a week
or two of standing water
in order for the eggs to hatch.
And then for one
mosquito to get infected,
it takes a blood meal.
And then it takes another
week for the virus
to kind of mature into its
life cycle in the mosquito
before the mosquito can bite
another person and pass it on.
So if it's dry, if it's
cool, and mosquitoes either
don't hatch-- there's a lot
of standing water around
for mosquitoes to
hatch-- or if they
don't live as long,
because when it's dry,
they desiccate
really easily, that
is going to dramatically
reduce mosquito populations.
And that's the conditions that
they're expecting in August.
Of course, we're living in
a time of disruptive weather
patterns.
And all you would
need is a couple weeks
of standing water around in,
like I said tiny, tiny bits.
Because the eggs of
the aegypti mosquito--
they desiccate, and then they're
all over the environment.
And as soon as you just
put a little water on them,
they come back to life.
Because they can be dormant
for weeks or even months.
That said, we're not going to
stop Zika from coming here,
whether we go to
the Olympics or not.
We have millions of Americans
going back and forth.
And we Zika's
probably already here
in a larger proportion
than we actually know.
Because of course, 80%
of people who get it
don't have any symptoms.
So we have a lot of silent
carriers who can travel.
And they'll never know that
they were infected at all.
And even the people
who do have symptoms,
it's so mild that you wouldn't
necessarily get diagnosed.
You would just think, oh, I
have a rash, a little fever.
It passes.
It's self limiting.
So it's very cryptic.
It can travel really far.
So whether we go or not,
Zika's going to come.
And it's probably already here.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Firstly,
thanks for coming.
Excellent presentation.
So what can Google do to
help track contagions?
Because we've already done
some things in this space.
We tried to correlate searches.
SONIA SHAH: Yes, like
Google Flu Trends.
AUDIENCE: Which had some
mixed results, apparently.
So what would you
recommend based
on all the different
resources and all
of the things we can do?
Because there's, of course,
lots of effort with Google
putting in volunteer work.
For example, when there
was the tsunami in Japan,
they put a ton of resources,
used all their tools to try
to come up with solutions.
What do you think we should
do on more of an ongoing basis
to track contagions?
SONIA SHAH: Not being as
familiar with everything
Google does as you
are, since I've
been living in this world of
pandemic disease for six years,
I do know there's
a lot to be done
with mapping and with predicting
where these new pathogens are
coming out.
There's new studies
showing that you
can correlate satellite data
of chlorophyll signatures
in the water, and predict
when cholera might outbreak
in Bangladesh and elsewhere.
And I wonder if there's
more ways to do that,
so that we could
actually come up
with a kind of forecasting
system like the way we forecast
the weather.
And if we had enough data
on the environment and all
these drivers that
bring pathogens out,
and how outbreaks occur,
that we could actually
have a forecasting for
disease-- a disease
forecast so you could
know in advance.
And that means
everything, because time
is completely of
the essence when
you think of these things
that can spread exponentially.
So if you know even days
or weeks in advance,
there's so much more
we can do to save lives
and to prevent all the
destruction of these outbreaks.
So I think there's lots of
opportunities in that area,
especially.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Sounds like antibiotic
has been a big problem.
And seems that over
70% of antibiotics
are used on livestock.
So how do you think we
can tackle this problem?
SONIA SHAH: Well, we
know that in places
where they don't use
antibiotics commercially,
and antibiotics are used
as they say rationally--
which is only when they're
medically necessary-- that they
don't have problems with
antibiotic-resistant bacteria.
So that is a known thing.
So the path forward is
actually really clear.
We need to use these
drugs rationally.
We need to steward these drugs.
We have not done that.
We've used them as commodities.
And so that's the thing.
The thing we have to
do is really simple.
It's difficult
politically, of course.
So that's going to
be the big hurdle.
And what we've seen
with Obama's recent--
the White House
recently passed--
they made some efforts,
some initiatives to try
to deal with this problem.
And there's two parts to it.
One part was let's try to reduce
use and use these rationally.
But first let's get
a committee to think
about it for a couple
years, and then
issues and recommendations.
On the other hand, the
other thing we can do
is, let's throw a lot of
money at drug companies
to come up with new antibiotics.
And then we can just keep using
them like as badly as we're
using them now.
But we'll just keep getting
new ones and getting new ones
and getting new ones.
Right now, drug
companies don't want
to create a lot of
antibiotics, because it's not
a very good market.
I mean, these are drugs you only
use for a week or two at most.
And people have been trained
to only want to pay $100 or so.
I mean, we'll pay hundreds
of thousands of dollars
for a cancer drug
that maybe will
extend life for a week at best.
But a lifesaving
antibiotic, we don't
want to pay more than $100.
So it's not a very
good market for them.
So that's one of the
parts of the initiative,
is to throw more money
and incentives at the drug
companies, so that
they'll actually
make us some new antibiotics.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
SONIA SHAH: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I've been reading in some
journals and articles
about the possibility of
having male mosquitoes which
are infertile, and introducing
them to the population
and trying to cut back
on mosquito populations.
Do you think that's
a viable solution
to cut back on mosquitoes?
Or do you think that's
kind of a stretch?
SONIA SHAH: I mean,
this is the thing-- you
introduce an infertile male.
And then it mates.
And they so they have no babies.
So you've done that once.
Now, that trait is not
going to get passed down.
So there's no like
sustainable chain of events.
You have just keep
doing this-- keep
introducing more and
more of these insects
in order to keep controlling
the population of mosquitoes.
So in that sense, it's not
that different than using
insecticides.
And what we know, that when
we throw killing chemicals
or reduce the ability of
living things to reproduce,
that they evolve in ways so
that they can get around that.
Because there's very strong
selection for creatures
to do that.
So to me, it's as promising
as a new insecticide.
It's not any more
promising than that.
And then you have all
the ethical problems
of places where
they already have
a lot of mosquito-borne disease,
and then people coming up,
white-coated people
coming up and releasing
more mosquitoes that
are special-- there's
going to be some
resistance to that,
I think, in local communities.
That could be an issue.
The other thing is a lot
of these diseases that
are caused by
mosquitoes, you don't
have to kill a lot of
mosquitoes to control them.
There's usually a time
period during which
the disease or pathogen inside
the mosquito has to develop,
has to have a life cycle.
So malaria takes
seven to 10 days.
Zika takes around the
same amount of time.
So you don't need
to kill them all.
You just need to
shorten their lives.
So if you just depress
the lifespan of mosquitoes
so that they don't live long
enough to pass on a pathogen,
then you can disrupt the
disease spread altogether.
And you won't be working
against evolution.
Because you're going
to allow these mosquito
populations to survive.
You're going to allow
them to reproduce.
You're just going to kill all
the grandmothers, basically.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thanks
for the great talk.
So from your talk, I feel a
huge part of preventing pandemic
is from nudging the general
public to pick up their life
habits.
So are you aware of any of the
current, ongoing policy which
could help us do it
better right now?
SONIA SHAH: You're talking
about individual behaviors that
could reduce risk?
What were you thinking?
What did you have in mind?
AUDIENCE: I'm
thinking because it's
kind of hard to really
control everyone,
and help prevent epidemic,
you could sort of
think about it as a collective
effort for everyone.
How do we do it better?
SONIA SHAH: Yeah, so
changing human behavior
is probably the hardest
part of all of these things.
I mean, we know that
washing your hands
would prevent the spread of
a lot of infectious diseases.
And people don't do that well.
We have a lot of
simple things we
could do that require
some behavior change that
could disrupt a lot
of these contagions.
But we don't do them.
And I think a good
example of that
is bed nets for malaria
control, where this
is a very simple thing to do.
You get a bed net.
You sleep under it every night.
And you don't get malaria,
this killer disease.
Well, when they first started
distributing those nets,
like 20% of the
people used them.
80% just thought, oh, this
is the most fancy thing
I've ever owned.
I'm going to keep
it in this chest
and when my fancy
uncle comes over,
I'll show him that I have this.
Or I'll use it for a wedding
veil, or fishing nets,
or whatever.
So that's why so
much of public health
is about coming up
with ways so that we
don't have to ask people to
change their behavior that
much.
So how do you engineer our
architecture, or our economy,
or all these other incentives
that shape human behavior?
How do you change that
part, so that doing
the disease-free or
disease-minimizing behavior
becomes easy?
It has to be the path
of least resistance.
We see even in hospitals that
doctors don't wash their hands
between patients.
I mean, that's kind of an
amazing thing-- so simple.
But simple solutions,
when it comes up
to complex human behaviors,
turn out to be not so simple.
AUDIENCE: Fantastic
talk, by the way.
You're a very
impressive speaker.
SONIA SHAH: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: One of the concerns--
back again towards the Zika
virus and how likely it is
already here in the United
States-- speaking
politically, what
are some of the things in your
study or someone in your field
that would raise a red
flag as part of, maybe,
a legislation that
would make us more
vulnerable to the
transmitting and the spread
of this particular virus?
SONIA SHAH: Well,
this is the thing.
Right now, we're talking about,
let's attack the mosquito.
We need more money
for mosquito control,
more insecticides to
depress mosquito populations
in the South and other the
parts of the United States
where we have Aedes mosquitoes
that could carry Zika virus.
And the fact is, it's
already too late to do that,
because these
populations of mosquitoes
are highly entrenched.
Their eggs are everywhere
in the environment.
You could maybe depress their
populations for a while,
but you're not going to
get rid of them anymore.
And it's an interesting
story of what happened--
how we got these mosquitoes.
Both of the Aedes mosquitoes
that are in this country
are invasive species.
Aedes albopictus, which
is the one that about 60%
of the United States
is vulnerable to--
and I live in Baltimore, and
there's tons of these things
around.
And you guys have
them up here, too,
I think when it's hot,
like in the summer when
it's really hot.
That's an invasive mosquito
that came over in the used tire
trade in the 1970s and 1980s.
And people are bringing tires.
In the wild, they
live in tree holes.
These mosquitoes
live in tree holes--
so a dark environment
with standing water.
And you think about a tire.
I mean, you can never get
the water out of a tire.
So these used tires
fill up with some water.
And the mosquitoes lay
their eggs in there.
And they survive this long
travel across from Asia.
We have distributed these
tires across the nation.
I mean, they're used
for embankments.
People throw them
over into streams
to build up the
streambeds for erosion.
They're recapped and then
put back into rotation.
They're also often
kept in giant piles
next to other giant piles
that have been sitting there
for a long time.
So even if they didn't come over
infested with these mosquito
eggs, they will get infested
while they're sitting there.
And so that's been
going on for decades.
And this happened with
the full knowledge
of our medical entomologists
and our medical community
that this was happening.
So that was the time
when we should have been
doing the mosquito control.
That was the time when we should
have said, let's quarantine,
inspect, and treat these tires.
Because the US military actually
knew that this was happening.
It started in the 1940s when
all of our surplus war materials
were coming back from
war zones in Asia.
And they found the tires were
just full of all these mosquito
eggs.
And so they started
treating them
so it wouldn't lead to an
invasion of these populations.
But once private
companies started
doing this, and bringing these
tires in container ships-- not
just a ship, but
these giant containers
and many, many containers--
we just didn't do it.
So we totally dropped the ball.
That's when the mosquito
control should have happened.
At this point, I
wonder, actually,
if immunity isn't our
best defense against Zika.
Once you get Zika, it looks
like you don't get it again.
That's what the science
looks like right now.
Of course, a lot more
needs to be learned.
But given that it is mild--
if you have your bout of Zika,
you may not even know you
have your bout of Zika.
But after that, you're immune.
Then you can have babies.
You can have sex,
do all these things.
You're not going to
endanger the child.
That's, of course,
the biggest risk.
So if we want to
build up immunity,
then it's a real question.
Should we depress
mosquito populations?
Because doesn't that mean
that fewer people are going
to get exposed to this virus?
I mean, if we all are able to
put off childbearing while we
develop immunity, or
protect our pregnant women
and protect our
childbearing people,
and let everybody
else get immunity--
but it's sort of an
anathematic disease.
It's just a totally
disruptive idea.
I mean, public health
authorities can't possibly say,
oh, we're just going
to let Zika come.
Everyone can get infected.
AUDIENCE: Say, hey, go to Puerto
Rico with your pregnant wife.
SONIA SHAH: Well, exactly.
And I think at the root
of it is sort of this idea
that we shouldn't be
vulnerable to contagion.
We had probably about 40
years from 1940 to 1980
or so, when we felt like
contagions were under control.
And we could live this
sort of germ-free life.
And if we did get an infection,
we could just take something.
And it'll be really
simple, and get over it.
And I think that has infiltrated
our thinking to such a degree
that when there is these
threats that maybe aren't
so bad for most of us--
I mean, most people are
going to be fine with Zika.
It's just really the
microcephaly in children
that's the main thing.
But we don't think
of it that way.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
SONIA SHAH: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Overall great
speech, very informative.
But the underlying
thing I've seen
that it seems to be the
advancement of the economy
that's really pushed this issue
of pandemics to the main stage,
through transportation
or economic advancement,
going into different areas
that weren't developed before.
I mean, is there an
international coalition
that's trying to create
standards to prevent this, when
we actually have workers
going internationally
to different areas that never
have been inhabited or visited
by humans ever,
to prevent spreads
of different contagions?
SONIA SHAH: So that would
be great if there was.
But of course, there isn't.
So this is all unregulated.
People can do what they want.
Some people go want to go in
Congo and start a mine there,
they just get the
appropriate licensing
from some corrupt governments,
and they can do that.
So that's the world we live in.
That said, economic
growth is still
really important for
controlling contagions, too.
We saw during the Ebola
outbreak in West Africa
that a lot of other nations
got really panicked and scared,
and started to cut down trade
and transportation links.
And this had a terrible
effect on the ability
of those countries to
control the disease.
Aid workers couldn't come in.
Commodities couldn't come in.
These are fragile
economies to begin with,
and they started
to really suffer.
And that completely
undermines their ability
to contain these pathogens.
So it's not a one-to-one thing
that economic-- we need both.
For getting rid of a
lot of these diseases,
we need more development and
more prosperity-- diseases
like malaria, which are very
much shaped by poverty-- just
living in poor circumstances.
You don't have window screens.
You have bad drainage around.
Lifting people out of poverty
through economic development
would actually do a lot to
control a disease like that.
AUDIENCE: I mean,
my question was more
pushing towards there's
no measures that's
done by the CDC.
For instance, if you visited
Europe in set period,
you can't give blood
because of mad cow.
They don't have anything
for workers that come back
internationally to screen
them properly medically,
and make sure that they
don't have any of these--
SONIA SHAH: I think there
probably is in an ad hoc way.
But the problem is, we're
talking about pathogens
that we don't know about.
So how do you screen for things
you don't know are there?
We don't really have the
diagnostics to do that.
So that piece of the puzzle
would be just technically
impossible at the moment.
AUDIENCE: Thanks
for a great talk.
So I think it's an
unfortunate truth
that the private and
public interests that
led to the cholera outbreak in
New York still exists today.
So what do you think we didn't
do in the last 100 years
that we should probably
not repeat in the next 100?
SONIA SHAH: I mean,
I think there's so
many lessons from the past that
are still applicable today.
So that was sort
of my main point,
is that all the ways in which
these old pandemics were
unfolding are still factors
today-- in fact, even more so.
Is that what you meant?
AUDIENCE: I'm
thinking mostly about
the private-public interest.
SONIA SHAH: So
what's happened now--
and I think it's actually
a little more worrisome--
is that we've divested
out of public health,
to a large degree.
The WHO, for
example-- we've been
under-financing that agency
since about the '80s.
Their budget has been getting
smaller and smaller every year
in terms of their membership
dues from member countries.
So what they've done is they've
turned to the private sector
to do partnerships to
maintain their budget.
So 80% or so of the
WHO budget is now
coming from these donations.
And that can be companies.
It can be NGOs.
It can be other governments.
It can be any kind
of entity, really.
But the problem is,
they earmark that money.
So the WHO is not in charge
of the majority of its budget.
Other entities are
in charge of that.
And there is no
democratic accountability
to what they decide.
So we know that 91% of
those extra-budgetary funds,
those donated funds
that the WHO gets--
are given over to diseases that
affect 8% of the global disease
burden.
So it is a huge mismatch.
So the WHO is not
able to really address
our global health priorities
because of these budgeting
issues.
And we've seen it
even with CDC now.
CDC is getting a lot more money
from private interests, too.
They're doing whole
campaigns that
are in partnership with drug
companies, and the sugar
industry, and a whole
bunch of other companies,
because that's how
they can continue
doing some work at all.
When the CDC tried to do gun
prevention violence research,
the NRA just shut them down.
And they slashed a whole
big part of their budget.
So it's very difficult for
these public health agencies
to tackle private interests.
And what they've been doing more
and more just collaborating.
So what we get is
public health-- we
have the Venn diagram of things
we can do for public health,
things we can do that will
protect economic interests,
and there's that overlap.
And that's what
our public health
community is able to do today.
But all those other things that
kind of fall outside of that
is much harder.
Thank you all so much.
It's been really
lovely being here.
[APPLAUSE]